hey welcome to every damn day I'm Hannah
Dickinson and it's Thanksgiving and I'm
the only one left and if you're watching
it that means you're alone too so let's
have a good time
[Music]
Happy Thanksgiving
politics can bring a lot of negative
energy to the table and that's your job
bring the conversation back to you this
is a tension hat these are tips I've
seen I've done you're welcome
step 1 brag giving thanks is an
effective way to brag because you have
the floor for example I am extremely
thankful that all my test results were
negative this year have one airpot in at
all times tell people you always have to
be plugged in because you trade
currencies no one will know what that is
because it's not a real job that way
anytime someone brings up politics or
current events you can pretend to hop on
a call Singapore buy high sell higher
flirt with your cousin sure some people
say it's taboo including the 24 states
that have deemed first cousin marriage
illegal but it's a great way to tell
your parents while you're single so they
stop asking get grandma hammered so you
sound less ignorant ask her what she
means by the bad part of town so that
way in comparison nothing you say is
racist order sushi to arrive 5 minutes
into the meal this is strictly a Power
Move a way of saying you have a worldly
palate and yes I anticipated this turkey
being dry you're welcome ABV always be
begging please offer to do the dishes do
it loudly enough that every single
person can hear your kind gesture but
only offer if there's a dishwasher and a
housekeeper to load it dig up your
family skeletons bring up your brothers
DUI when people ask why you can't afford
a car or your dad's pill problem when
they ask what you don't have health
insurance or your grandfather's eyepatch
when you're called out for wearing a
crop top at least I don't look
ridiculous it might seem like just as
shifting the focus off of you but the
hate they will send back will more
make up for it this is attention hacks
you're welcome
this is cheers to you and this week I'm
drinking heavily and on our Black Friday
to reach a level of desperation you feel
about next box cheers to you Black
Friday for being created to promote
holiday shopping with great big sales
that make white women wet why do you
think they call it Black Friday cheers
to you Walmart for opening at 4 p.m. on
Thanksgiving now customers can fight
someone outside their family and cheer
see Walmart for your light-up Black
Friday party it'll have free cookies and
coffee like every super fun addiction
meeting and cheers to you Walmart bakery
there is a Walmart bakery I've heard of
the Walmart of bakeries that's a Panera
cheers to you REI for staying closed on
Black Friday and encouraging people to
hashtag opt outside way to promote your
company in a healthy way like on Twitter
it's a good thing you're closed on Black
Friday no one has ever survived the
Stampede and Birkenstocks cheers to you
Sears for participating in Black Friday
sales after filing for bankruptcy in
October
it'll be opening at 6 p.m. on Thursday
in case any Black Friday shoppers need
to take a cheers to you cyber
monday for being even more popular than
Black Friday you provide all of the
materialism and none of the eye contact
the true spirit of Christmas
Cheers
[Music]